قمه سعوديه صينيه في الرياض للدفع بشراكه
الاقتصاديه بين الجانبين الى مرحله جديده
مسؤولون في النظام الايراني يبحثون اللجوء
الى فنزويلا وحلفاء اخرين تحسبا لتدهور
الوطن
اوروبا تقترح عقوبات جديده ضد الجيش
والبنوك الروسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير
تحتضن الرياضه اليوم قمه صينيه سعوديه
للدفع بالعلاقات الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
الرئيس
السعودي الملك سلمان وولي عهده الامير
محمد بن سلمان التعاون الثنائي والقضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه
مع السعوديه
وبشكل مستمر
[موسيقى]
مجموعته مصالح متبادله تدفع باتجاه تعزيز
العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه فيما ترى
الرياضه في الشركه الصيني مزايا تعزيز
مصالحها السياسيه والاقتصاديه والامنيه
تبحث بكين عما يعزز مكانتها ويحسن صورتها
عربيه
تجمع الرياضه
من الدوافع المتبادله فاولويات العلاقه مع
الشريك الصينيه تتمثل بالتعاون غير
المشروط اي غياب اي شروط صينيه في
الانفتاح على مزيد من افاق التعاون بين
الجانبين
عشان يرجعوا على القهوه
بل يدخلوا ضمن سياسه التوسع شرقا
واستراتيجيه تعدد البدائل والتحالفات وان
كان بمستويات متفاوته الا ان الصين
استحوذت على الحصه الكبرى لامكانياتها
الاقتصاديه وموقعها بمجلس الامن سياسه
تبعث برسائل لبعض حلفاء المملكه بعدم
رهن المصالح لخيارات دوله محدده مهما
كانتها
ودمنا مزايا التعاون تدخل السوق الصينيه
المتعطشه للنفط ومصادر الطاقه في الصين
التي تعد رابع منتجا النفط في العالم
تعتمد على الاستيراد كذلك بسبب ارتفاع
الطلبه اكثر من الانتاج المحليه وهنا تاتي
محاوله ابعاد الصين عن ايران او على الاقل
اضعاف في علاقتها بها وبالتالي تقليل
الحاجه الصينيه لنفت الايراني وزياده ضغط
العقوبات على طهران من جهتها تستقطب
السعوديه لاهتمام الصيني من منطلق موقعها
بالمنطقه العربي
ومركزيه قرارها فاتعاون مع المملكه يطفي
مشروعيه على سياسه الصين الخارجيه وثقلها
بالمنطقه وموازين القوه الدوليه كما يخلق
فرصا لتحسين صورتها بالعالم العربي
تعاون يصب ايضا في زاويه مستلزمات مشروعها
الاستراتيجي المتمثل بطريق الحرير بحكم
الموقع الجغرافي للسعوديه
وامكانياتها الماديه
مرحله تطوير التماشي مع تغيرات العصر
البلدين دخلت العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه
علما بان هذه العلاقه مبنيه على اكثر من
70 عاما من التعاون والتنسيق والشبكه
الاستراتيجيه في كافه المجالات
بسيطه جذور بنيت عليها العلاقات السعوديه
الصينيه الممتده منذ 77 عاما
[تصفيق]
العلاقات التي ابتسمت ببساطه اوليه اتخذت
شكلها الرسمي قبل 32 عاما بعد اتفاق
البلدين على اقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه كامله
وتبادل السفراء وتنظيم اجتماعات على
مستويات سياسيه واقتصاديه وغيرها
[تصفيق]
محطات عده تبعت هذه المرحله كتشكيل لجنه
سعوديه صينيه مشتركه عام 2004 برئاسه وزير
خارجيه البلدين والاتفاق على بدء حوارا
سياسيا منتظمه تبعها الاعلان عن اقامه
علاقات الصداقه الاستراتيجيه عام 2008
[تصفيق]
من محطاتها كذلك زيارتان للملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز اولها في عام 99 حين كان اميرا
لمنطقه الرياض اما الثانيها في عام 2014
كوليا للعهد وكانت تاكيد مجددا على
اعتزازه بمستوى العلاقات الثنائيه التي
تشمل مختلف اوجه التعاون المشتركه
[تصفيق]
وما بينها زيارات لرؤساء الصينيين للمملكه
ملفاتهم مره اخرى شملت التشديد على
التعاون والتشاور والتنسيق سعيا لتعزيز
السلم والامن اقليميا ودوليا
وهنا المواقف ثابته عند ضروره ايجاد تسويه
سياسيه عاجله للمساله السوريه ووحده اليمن
وسيادته
[تصفيق]
من دوليه لقاءات لولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان بالرئيس الصيني احدها في قمه دول
مجموعه العشرين بالارجنتين عام 2018
اعقبها بزياره الى بكين في العام التالي
حرص على تبادل الزيارات رفيعه المستوى غزه
علاقه متسارعه ومتطوره بتقادم السنين ان
عكست على شركات ومجموعه التفاهمات
بالمجلات الاقتصاديه تذهب باتجاه المواكمه
بين مبادره الحزام والطريق ورؤيه 2030
فالسعوديه الشريك الرئيسي للجمهوريه
الشعبيه في المنطقه وفق مسؤولينا سينين
[موسيقى]
فراس خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز اجتماع مجلس الوزراء
السعوديه
العهد رئيسه مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن
سلمان على الميزانيه العامه
وبعد توقيعه على ميزانيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لعام 20 23 اكيد ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان ان ميزانيه
العامل تدعم الاتفاق الاستراتيجي والانفاق
الاستراتيجي ومبادرات الاستثمار بشكل كبير
وتحقق مستهدفات التحول الاقتصادي شيدا
بالمواطن السعودي الذي اعتبره اعظم ما
تملكه المملكه التي تسعى جاهده لتوفير
مستوى المعيشي كريم خصوصا للفئات الاقل
دخلا واوضح ولي العهد انما تحقق من نتائج
ايجابيه وفق توجيه خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز يؤكد نجاح
الاصلاحات وشددا على ان المملكه
واستقرار الاقتصاد العالمي والمحلي وقال
الامير محمد بن سلمان من مليون جنيه
ومئتين مليون سعودي يعملون في القطاع
الخاص وهو الرقم الاعلى تاريخيا مض انا
مشاركه المراه السعوديه في الاقتصاد
ارتفعت من
17.7% الى 35.6%
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه اشاره محمد
الجدعان وزير الماليه السعودي الى ان
العبد الضريبيه الاجمالي على القطاع الخاص
لا يزال في المملكه اقل من المستوى الموصى
به عالميا واضاف الجدعان ان نسبه الدين من
الناتج المحلي في السعوديه يعتبر اقل من
متوسط مجموعه العشرين
اقتصاد المملكه امن المهم جدا ان تنظر الى
مجموعه من العلويه
والاصلاح الهيكل اللي احيانا يتطلب النظره
الثانيه
المهم هو كم اجمالي العب الاقتصادي على
القطاع الخاص من الرسوم
في الدراسات صندوق النقد الدولي حتى
المؤسسات دوليه الاخرى بما في ذلك ال ال
او اي سي سي دي او منظمه التجاره والتعاون
الاقتصادي الدولي
الاوبتيمال بالنسبه للدوله مثل المملكه
اللي هي منتجه
للمواد خام تقريبا 21% من 19 الى 21%
اللاعب الضريبي
في المملكه حاليا تقريبا
16.16.9% فما زال العبد الضريبه الاجمالي
على القطاع الخاص اقل من المتوسط همم
الدول الاخرى
الحكومه تنظر بشكل يعني مستمر له دوري مع
وزاره الاقتصاد وزاره الماليه وجهات اخرى
بما في ذلك مركز في مركز الحكومه الى كيف
يمكن ان نحسن من ذلك كيف يمكن ان نخفف
العباءه بماذا الكعباء
والامتثال على القطاع الخاص فيما يتعلق
بهذه الشريحه اللي نعتقد انها كبيره حاليا
متعدده من الرسوم والمقابلات الماليه في
دراسه قائمه لمحاوله وضعها بطريقه تساعد
القطاع الخاص لكن لا تزال في اطار تقريبا
الايراد متوسط الايرادات الحاليه بس الان
لا قرار بتغييره حاليا
همم ما في ذكرت اي توجه لاطفاء همم دين
بالفتره القادمه لماذا هل لك ان توضح لنا
بالنسبه
همم نسبه الدين الى الناتج المحل الاجمالي
في السعوديه
اقل من متوسط مجموعه 20 مجموعه 20 اذا
اخرجنا المملكه تقريبا 85% متوسط الدائره
الناتج محل الاجمالي في المملكه تقريبا
مقفل سنه 22 على تقريبا 24 فاصل تسعه اقل
من 25% فما زال عندنا مجال السؤال هو ليس
زياده الدين او تخفيضه والسؤال هل من
المصلحه هل في عائد انك تستدير اكثر
وبالتالي تستخدم هذه الاموال في عناصر
منتجه في الاقتصاد تحقق لك عائد اكبر اذا
الاجابه نعم سنه اكثر
لكن اخدا في الاعتبار طبعا اوضاع السوق
تكلفه الدين اللي بدات ترتفع من المهم اذا
راتها بحصافه مركز اداره الدين عمل عمل
مميز صراحه خلال سنوات السابقه جزء من
الديون اللي تستحق سنه 23 وبعضها سنه 25
في سنه 21 سنه 22 22
ستتحق في المستقبل او حتى التمويل البديل
همم عندنا خيارات كبيره جدا لتمويل بعض
البنيه التحتيه
المياه
المعالجه الصرف الصحي وغيرها من البنيه
التحتيه اللي قد نستخدم التمويل البديل
فاصل قصيده لاستكمال
اهلا بكم من جديد نقلت قناه ايران
انتظارنال عن مصادر الدبلوماسيه غربيه في
النظام الايراني دخلوا في محادثات ايران
الاجانب ومن بينهم فنزويلا من اجل مسؤولي
النظام وعائلتهم تحسبا لتدهور الاوضاع في
ايران التي تشهد انتفاضه شعبيه في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه ترفع منذ ثلاثه اشهر
تقريبا بشعارات
صحيفه نيويورك الامريكيه اشاره الى اكثر
من 50 مدينه اغلقت محلها تجاريه في احد
اكبر الاضرابات العامه التي تشهدها ايران
منذ عقود
مع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في الشوارع
الايرانيه والممتده منذ سبتمبر الماضي ضد
نظام طهران وفقا الصحيح
[تصفيق]
المتسوقون وضجيجهم اختفوا من هذه الاصدقاء
الضيقه في اسواق طهران فلا بقاله ولا جزار
ولا حتى صيدليه الا وحرصت على المشاركه في
تنفيذ قرار بدا شعبيا بامتياز
هذا المشهد وتكرر في اكثر من 50 مدينه
ايرانيه اغلق تجارها ابواب محالهم ولا
بونداء دعوات المنسقه للاضراب لمده ثلاثه
ايام
الايرانيون الذين انتقلوا من الاحتجاج
ليلا من اسطح منزلهم خوفا من قمع الحرس
الثوري يضربون في وضع النهار ويعلنون
مواقفهم بمشاركه واسعه من الطبقه العامله
من كل الفئات
شعبه النظام من التهديد واساليب القمع
التي لجا اليها لاخافه الايرانيين يبدو
انها خلت فمن قتل الميداني واحكام الاعدام
الصادره عن قضاء النظام والسجن والسحلب
بالاضافه الى التحرش باطفال واغتصاب
لفتيات كلها اعمال كشف عنها نشطاء ومراكز
حقوقيه تحت عنوان جرائم ارتكبها النظام
ونددت بها مؤسسات حقوقيه دوليه ومحليه
والان يهدد النظام الغاء التراخيص
التجاريه واعتقالي اصحابها
احتجاجات الايرانيين ضد نظام طهران تختلف
عن سابقاتها هذه المره فهي الاطول زملا
كما تتميز بتحد يوصف بالكبير ورغم توقعات
خبراء ان تلك تظاهرات لن تسقط النظام
الحليب الا انها تشكل هزه كبيره بحقه
تنازلات ابدا نظام مرغما على تقديمها في
محاوله الاحتواء الوضع الداخلي لكن الشارع
يصفها بتنازلات مخادعه
حنان المصري العربيه
[تصفيق]
عز الدين
حركه المواطنين على طول بعض الطرق العامه
يعتبر المستشار الالمانيه ان خطر نجوم
موسكو الى سلاح النووي في حربها في
اوكرانيا قد تضائل لان المجتمع الدولي رسم
خط احمر لروسي على هذا الصعيد
هذا شغل هذا التراجع الى رسم المجتمع
الدولي ومن ضمن الصين خطا احمر لموسكو
بشان تهديداتها تلك
وكان رئيس الوسيط اقر بان الحرب ستكون
طويله الامد محذرا من الخطر
جندي من الاحتياط التحقوا بما يدين القتال
في اوكرانيا بحسب رئيس الروسيه الذي اكد
انه لا حاجه لعمليه تعبئه العسكريه جديده
في الوقت راح
وتظمن مع تصريحات بوتن التصعيديه قالت
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسنال لاين ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي اقترح حزمه عقوبه تاسعه
على روسيا تشمل نحو 200 شخص وكيان وثلاثه
بنوك
تستهدف حرمان روسيا من الحصول على طائرات
مسيره سواء بشكل مباشر او غير او غبره بلد
ثالث مثل ايران
اله الدعايه الروسيه من خلال اقتراح حجب
اربع قنوات اخرى
في المقابل اعلنت بولندا موافقتها على نشر
بطاريات صواريخ باتريوت داخل اراضيها
لحمايه امنها تواصل اوروبا الشرقيه
جديد الدعم الغربيه الى اوكرانيا موافقه
بولندا على عرض الماني يقضي بنصب بطاريه
صواريخ باتريوت على اراضيها القرار
البولندي وحسب وزير الدفاعها جاء بعد رفض
برلين ارسال المنظومه الدفاعيه الى
اوكرانيا
اتخذنا قرارات عمليه بشان مكان نصب
البطاريه وربطها بمنظومه القياده لتعزيز
امن بولندا واوكرانيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو ومعهم الولايات
المتحده يواصلون تعزيز الترسانه العسكريه
على الجبهه الشرقيه
لحمايتها من تهديدات روسيا حيث نشرت
واشنطن منظومه صواريخ باتريوت في بولندا
رغم ان تعاض روسيا
صفقه بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات و750 مليون
دولار لتزويدها بمئه وسته عشر دبابه من
طرازي ابرامز واسلحه ثقيله متنوعه وثمانيه
جس محموله للعمليات الهجوميه كما اشترت
بولندا 250 دبابه ابرامز من الولايات
المتحده في ابري الماضي لتعزيز قوتها
العسكريه
الخارجيه الامريكيه اعتبرت الصفقه
العسكريه بانها ستعزز قدره بولندا على
مواجهه التهديدات خاصه وانها قد تعرضت
مؤخرا الى سقوط صاروخ على قريه قرب الحدود
مع اوكرانيا ما اثرما خوف من ان روسيا قد
هاجمت احدى دول النيترو بولندا ستكون
قادره على ردع الخصوم والمشاركه في عمليات
النت ومن خلال تزويدها بقوه ذات مصداقيه
في المقابل رفض وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطونيو بلانكين استهداف قواعد عسكريه
داخل الاراضي الروسيه
لم نشجع ولم يمكن الاوكرانيين من تنفيذ
ضربات داخل روسيا رغم ان موسكو تستخدم
الشتاء السلاحا وتهاجمه البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه
وارسل الدول النايت واسلحه بمليارات
الدولارات الى اوكرانيا لمساعدتها على
التصدي للهجوم الروسي بينها منظومات دفاع
جوي حديثا ساهمت في تغيير مسار المعارك
على الارض
واجبرت لكرملين على اعاده حساباته
العسكريه جاسم محسن العربيه
اغلق ومحتاجون للبناء الجنوبي في ولايه
البحر الاحمر شرق السودان لعدم اشراقين في
الاتفاق الايطالي
لا حرام
العوده تاكل فيهم وانتم قاعدين في الوصول
وفي حاطه هنا بابا مجلس الامن قال الممثل
الاممي فولكس ان الاتفاق النهائي سيعمل
على مشكلات على حل مشكلات يعاني منها
الشعب السوداني وعلى راسها الحكومه
المدنيه
يمكنها ان تتصدى لكل الازمات الاثنين
والانسانيه والاقتصاديه كما ينبغي لها ان
تمهيد السبيل من اجل بناء دوله ديمقراطيه
تستند الى حقوق الانسان وزياده القانون
والمساواه بين الجنسين بل وترسم مستقبلا
لشباب وشابات السودان كما سيؤدي ذلك الى
استئناف محادثات السلامه مع الحركات
المختلفه التي لم تبرم السلام مع الحكومه
واضافه لتقديم المساعدات والدعم الدولي
الواسع النطاق
ذكرت الوكاله الرسميه تونسيه من نقابه
اصحاب المخابز قررت الغاء اضراب الذي بدا
تنفيذه اليوم وذلك اثر تلقي وعود حكميه
بمعالجه الملفات العالقه وقالت النقابه
انها تلقى الالتزاما من السلطات بدفع
المتاخرات التي تناهز 75 مليون دولار
في نهايه العالم
قمه سعوديه اصيليه في الرياض للدفع بشراكه
الاقتصاديه بين الجانبين الى مرحله جديده
مسؤولون في النظام الايرانيه يبحثون
اللجوء الى فنزويلا وحلفاء اخرين تحسبا
لتدهور الوضع
وتزامل مع تهديدات بوتين اوروبا تقترح
عقوبات جديده ضد الجيش والبنوك
نهايه هذه النشره شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]